Así se ve desde el aire el barrio de
bañados en Asunción aquí unas 100.000
personas viven en condiciones precarias
entre calles de tierra batida que se
convierten en charcos cada vez que
llueve
Gloria es una líder comunitaria premiada
por el proyecto de las Ollas populares
una iniciativa solidaria que inició
durante la pandemia para mitigar el
hambre entre sus vecinos
es un barrio Que prácticamente no tiene
nada no tenemos educación digna no
tenemos un techo digno no tenemos
alimentación los bañados surgieron hace
70 años por los flujos migratorios desde
las áreas Rurales millares de campesinos
fueron expulsados del campo primero por
caudillos locales y después por la
mecanización del cultivo de la soja es
de una calle transitada y mira Cómo está
Solamente insistimos en época electoral
unos dos millones de paraguayos tienen
ingresos inferiores al costo de una
canasta básica el 4% de la población
vive en condiciones de pobreza extrema
buenas Buen día desde hace 10 años
Arturo atiende a los casi 5.000
pacientes de la chacarita otro barrio
humilde de la capital paraguaya falta de
medios los asaltos y las malas
condiciones laborales marcan el día a
día de estos profesionales durante la
campaña electoral ha surgido la
propuesta de la privatización del
sistema sanitario algo que estos médicos
rechazan se dice haz un mayor control de
los recursos una mejor asignación yo
creo que sí fue el estado puede seguir
funcionando como administrador y rector
de la salud pública en nuestro país
pobreza y salud dos de los principales
retos para quien aspiran al cargo de
presidente de Paraguay para los próximos
cinco años